I've been trading for 14 years and have
tested hundreds of complicated
strategies, but none of them work as
well as the daily sweep. And ironically,
this is the easiest one of them all. I
use this strategy to break the world
record for the highest proper payout of
$2.5 million. And today, I'm going to
break down the strategy into three
simple steps. Let's hop on a chart for
step one. While this is simple, if you
guys mess this up, then nothing else is
going to work. So, you have to do
exactly as I say. So, what that look
usually looks like for a morning routine
is I'm waking up around 6:45, 7:00 a.m.
I usually get a morning walk in. I have
my coffee. I meditate. I read for a
little bit. And then I'm usually sitting
there around my charts around 8:00 a.m.
to 8:30 a.m. So, when I sit down in
front of my charts, what I actually do
is I plot out all of the hourly swing
points from the previous day. Now,
that's including leading up to 8 a.m.
So, it doesn't have to be previous day.
It could be all of the hours leading up
to 8 a.m. That includes London session,
Asian session. So, when I sit down in
front of my charts, I'm going to mark
out this high here, right? This swing
point here, right? So, this candle here
that we're looking at right now, this
candle opened at 7 and it closes at 8.
So, if you hover over this, you guys can
see at the bottom of the screen, it says
7:00 a.m. and that's closing at 8. So,
if this candle closed, that means we
have this swing point here. We have this
swing point up here. Now, we are only
marking swing points that haven't yet
been traded to. So, any swing points
that you see, like this one in here, we
are not going to mark that because it's
already been traded through. So, what
we're going to do is just mark out all
of the previous day swing points. Now,
if we're trading beyond the previous
day's swing highs, then we're just going
to use the next most recent high. So,
let's say, for example, you look at this
specific day and you have see these
swing points in here and you know,
market's trading past that. Well, what
we're going to do is go back to the next
day because that's the next most recent
data. And you're going to plot this
swing point and then this swing point up
here. So, as you guys can see, we've
marked out this specific prior day. You
know, we can mark out this one all the
way down here. Although, I doubt that
it's going to trade down there because
it's so far away. And that's just one
chart. Okay, this really only takes me
about 5 to 10 minutes to go through all
of my markets, to go through all of the
assets that I'm trying to trade for the
following day. And it doesn't take me
that long. Okay. All right. Let's go
through one more example here. So again,
this candle 7 8 a.m. I'm going to sit
down and plot out all of the previous
swing points that haven't yet been
traded to. You can even plot out the
ones that have been traded to just so
you have an idea. But I've marked out,
you know, all of these swing points in
here, including the Asian session from
all the way back here. So, we have these
previous daily swing points on the
hourly chart that we could pay attention
to. All right, this process is very
quick. It's very simple. You have to
understand what a swing point is. And
then when you sit down, you only take 5
to 10 minutes to plot out these swing
points. Now, again, this should only
take you about 5 to 10 minutes to sit
down in front of your charts and plot
out these swing points. That way, you at
least know going into the session, these
are the levels that I'm interested in.
Now, here's where things really get
interesting. You have these levels
marked, but if you just blindly trade
every sweep of these levels, you're
going to get destroyed. Now, there's a
specific confirmation we need to wait
for that I learned after losing tens of
thousands of dollars doing this wrong.
And I'm going to show you exactly what
that looks like in step two. But before
we get to that confirmation process,
remember this is the strategy I used to
break the world record at Apex. I have a
link that gets you an 80% discount or if
you use code Jada at checkout, I'll
leave that link in the description. All
right, so now that you understand swing
points, let's tie it together with some
type of confirmation because without
this step, you won't get anywhere. And
here's what most people do wrong. You
see concepts like turtle soup or ICT's
liquidity raid and you think, "Okay,
price sweeps to higher low. Let me just
enter immediately and ride it back." And
that's what I did for years. I would see
an old high like this be rated and I
would immediately enter short and the
market would just continue trading
higher, hit my stop loss, and then
eventually turn around. And I probably
spent thousands of dollars and way too
many years trying to figure out what I'm
about to show you right now. Instead of
entering a trade as soon as we raid that
liquidity level, what we're actually
looking for is a raid above a level and
then a closure back below the range.
Now, if the candle just trades up and
then it trades back down, but it hasn't
yet closed, that is not confirmation
yet. What we're looking for is a candle
closure. And this is what's going to
help you out to avoid getting into
trades too early. So, if you're watching
this and you're constantly stuck on the
lower time frame, what you should be
doing is waiting for a higher time frame
closure of these levels. So, if I'm
looking at an hourly chart, essentially,
I'm treating this hourly chart as my
high time frame. And what I'm looking
for on a higher time frame is for us to
raid one of these levels out. So, we're
going to sweep out one of these levels
and then I'm going to wait for a closure
back into the range until I get this
closure. I do not look at any of these
lower time frames. Now, I know where
most of you struggle because this is
where I struggled for many years. I
would go into the charts and if I didn't
see something on the hourly, I would
just drop down to the 30 minute, the
15-minut, the 5m minute, the 1 minute,
and just constantly scroll through these
time frames until I found something. And
that is not proper trading. You're
trading without a plan, and you're
gambling. So, what did I have to do to
fix these issues of getting into trades
too early? I had to wait for
confirmation. Now, this filter of
waiting for a closure back into the
range changed my trading tremendously.
So, it allowed me to stop front running
markets, meaning I didn't enter as soon
as we raided the high or the low. I
would wait for a confirmation first to
show me the market was willing to turn
around. And when you wait for a closure,
that's when you know you have an
extremely high probability setup cuz the
market is telling you that it's
rejecting these highs or lows. So, you
now know how to find your levels and
wait for confirmation, but you're still
missing the one crucial piece which took
me from being break even for many, many
years to making consistent six-figure
months, which is the execution. So,
let's go back to our first example here,
and we'll fast forward through price
action and wait and see if we get some
type of reaction around the equity open.
So, right now, it's 8:00 a.m. in the
morning, and we're going to fast forward
a couple candles. So, there's one. Now,
this candle closed at 9:00 and this
candle closed at 10. Now, at the 9:00
a.m. candle, we actually got a swing
failure because we raided the swing high
and closed back in the range. But maybe
you're a little nervous because it
closed bullish. So, we're going to wait
for one more candle. Now, we actually
have a very strong rejection of this
level. So, now we have two candles that
have failed to continue trading higher.
So, we're going to do now is drop down
into the lower time frame. And this is
right around 10:00 a.m. So, at 9:55,
we're looking for a low time frame
execution. Again, we are only using the
5minut time frame when we have the
higher time frame telling us which
direction the market wants to go. So at
the equity open, right, it pumped a
little bit higher and then rejected that
old swing high again and then we get a
closure down here. Now what do we have
here? This is our entry model. So we
have a bearish order block being formed.
So we have this series of upclose
candles and we've broken below the low.
So this gives us what? We have a bearish
order block and a breaker that it's
aligned with each other. Okay, what
we're going to do here because we have
this confirmation of this bearish order
block and the breaker that overlaps with
it is we're going to go short here and
we're going to put our stop above the
breaker. Okay? And then we're just going
to aim for 2 R. Now, this is the part of
execution that is going to change for
every one of you. Where you put your
stop loss and where you put your target
is going to vary, but the process of
getting to this decision that we're
going to short the market should be the
same for all of you. All right? So,
based on the higher time frame, we're
looking for swing points and then we're
looking for the confirmation. If we have
both of those, every single trader
that's watching this video is going to
have a different stop-loss and a
different target and a different entry.
So once we have all of these things in
place, the execution part is what you
need to practice. Okay, this is what
requires reps, requires experience, and
you can't just blindly trade a strategy
because you might have a trade where you
might have had too tight of a stop-loss,
but it eventually worked out. So over
time, you'll learn that, okay, maybe
maybe I need to work on my stop-loss
placement or maybe I need to work on my
targets or maybe I need to work on my
entries. Those are things that have an
infinite ceiling. Those specific aspects
of your trading have a high ceiling for
your skill level. So now that we have
our entry and a logical stop-loss
placement above this breaker here, let's
fast forward and see if this trade
actually pans out. All right, so running
through this trade again, we had
everything aligned. So step one,
plotting all of our swing points. Step
two, waiting for some type of
confirmation. Okay, the confirmation on
the hourly then allows us to drop down
to the lower time frame to find an entry
with a stop and a target. Now, you can
and you should have two different types
of exits. You either have a fixed target
or you should have a time exit. So, when
I talk about time exits, that means
leading up to lunch, you should be
taking some risk off of the table.
Whether that's taking a partial or
adjusting your stop-loss so you don't
have full risk on. Either one of those
is a mechanical decision that you should
make leading up to 11:00 a.m. and 12 pm.
All right, so let's jump to example
number two here. Again, at 8 a.m., I'll
sit down and plot out all the previous
day swing points. Let's say we avoided
this day because we didn't get a swing
failure on this specific day. So, if you
were to plot out all the swing highs and
you had a bearish bias, trading up into
this fair value gap at the open, right?
We didn't actually get a swing high
being rated. So, let's say we just
didn't take this specific trade. Now,
we're going to do is again fast forward
to equity open and see what we get. So,
this candle closed at 9 and this candle
closes at 10. So again, we're looking
for one of these swing highs to be rated
and then we get a closure. So here we
have a closure here, right? That
confirms that this market is rejecting
these highs. So then and only then do I
drop down into a 5minute time frame to
see if we could find a setup in here. So
it's about 10:00 a.m. and let's just
fast forward to see if we get any type
of setup. So there's really nothing in
here that I would honestly trade.
Everything is very choppy off of the
open. You know, we do have a bit of a
sellside imbalance here. So we do have a
bit of a bearish pair value gap here.
So, fast forwarding through a bit of the
equity open leading up to 10:30. Uh, we
do have this bearish fair value gap
here, but I do not like the way that
it's trading through it and then
closing. So, uh, let's just say that
this is a trade that we're going to
avoid for the time being. Okay, we do
have another fair value gap that's
appearing up here. Now that we've traded
into that fair value gap, let's say we
tried and attempted to short here and
put our stop loss here and maybe just
target at 2 R again. Now, let's see how
this trade plays out. So, obviously,
this trade did not pan out. Let's just
go back to our hourly time frame and see
if we get a rejection from this high
again. Okay, we have one more rejection
from this high. Now, what I tend to do
on a day-to-day basis, let's say if this
market is very choppy in the morning and
I took a loss, I'll only give myself one
more attempt on the day to get this
right. So, what I'm going to do here is
we do have some lower time frame levels
in here. We have this fair value gap
here and we have this fair value gap up
here. Now, if we flip back to our hourly
time frame, what we're going to see is
that this market is trading a little bit
higher into this bearish order block
that we have. So, it's okay to see this
market on the hourly time frame trade a
bit higher into this level. Right? The
morning session was a bit choppy. What
I'm going to do is give myself one more
attempt at this. Now, what I typically
do on a day-to-day basis is I give
myself two attempts. So, let's say the
AM session, we had our strategy that
panned out. We had step one, which is
plotting out all of our swing points,
and then we waited for confirmation,
which we got, and then we took a short
attempt and ended up being a loser. Now,
I'll give myself one more attempt in the
PM session. Okay, if I lose during the
PM session again, I will stop for the
day. Now, if we come to the charts
during the PM session, which for me is
about 1:00 p.m. till about 400 p.m. If I
come to the charts and I see that the
market has been choppy leading up to
that point, what I'll typically do is
not rely so much on a lower time frame.
And what I'll tend to do is use a higher
time frame level like a 1 hour high or
low as my stop loss, but still use a
lower time frame for my entry. So here I
can tell that the market does have some
bearish fair value gaps in the PM
session. What I'm going to do is
actually use this hourly high as my
stop-loss placement. So let's say I'm
going to attempt to short here and I'm
going to put my stop above this hourly
high because the market has been choppy
and I just don't trust that a 5minut
stop loss is going to allow me enough
flexibility for this trade to pan out.
So, let's just assume that we are going
to use this hourly high that's all the
way back here because it's conservative
and it's safe and we don't have to worry
about intraday noise, which is
essentially what we're seeing so far
today. So, let's just assume that we
went short here and again used an hourly
level as our stop loss and still target
a 2R. Okay, it traded up into a 5minute
fair value gap. Now, let's see if it
expands lower and takes out some of
these lows down in here. Now, as you
guys can see, this PM session trade did
pan out. But I want to walk you guys
through the lower time frame price
action and why you can't always trust
these low time frame levels to provide
stop-loss placements. You guys see this
5minute fair value gap here? It traded
up through that level and never even
makes it to this next 5m minute fair
value gap and then it rolls over. But if
you're just relying on hourly stop-loss
levels, right, your higher time frame
level as a stop-loss, and you're still
going to use that lower time frame for
some type of specific entry, then it
actually does pan out in your favor.
Now, let's just assume I didn't enter on
this candle and I entered on one of
these candles around 1 p.m. You guys can
see that it does trade through that fair
value gap against where I want the
market to go and against where a logical
stop-loss using a lower time frame would
work. But using a higher time frame
stop-loss placement like the previous
hourly high, it gives me enough room
where this market is going to be able to
wiggle around a bit and chop around as
we've seen all day before it makes its
run to the target. Now, I can't
emphasize this enough. Steps one and two
should be very, very simple and they
shouldn't take you a long time. Now,
step three, putting it all together, is
where the majority of your work when
testing the system and trading it live
is going to be. So, where do I enter the
market? Where do I put my stop loss?
Where do I put my target? Now, let's say
if you're just a low time frame trader
and you entered short on this fair value
gap and you put your stop loss above
candle one of that fair value gap. If
you go back and study your trade idea,
was your trade idea wrong or was your
stop-loss placement wrong? Cuz
eventually the trade idea panned out,
but your stop-loss placement was too
tight inside of the market condition
that is sideways. So, if you determine
that the market condition is kind of
choppy and it's kind of sideways, you're
always better off using a higher
timeframe stop-loss. So maybe you don't
want to just rely on one specific fair
value gap. Maybe you put your stop loss
above the next fair value gap to give
yourself that bit of wiggle room. Now
when you're testing the system and
trying to trade it live again remember
your trading is not going to be perfect.
You're going to have to learn through
repetition where do I put my stop losses
that are in a logical area. Where do I
put my targets and how do I manage that
trade effectively? You now have the same
strategy that I used to make millions of
dollars and change my life forever.
Well, chances are you've probably had
profitable strategies before, but still
didn't become profitable. And I get it
because I failed for 10 years before I
was able to make it work. But once I
did, my life changed forever. Please
guys, whatever you do, just stay
consistent with this because trading
really can change your life if you have
the right system. I recently open up
spots to my inner circle where I trade
with my students, give them my full
system, and coach them to become
successful traders and overcome the
hurdles that are keeping them stuck. Due
to this being a direct mentorship, I
only work with a limited number of
traders. If the link in the top of the
description works, then slots are open.
If not, feel free to apply for the next
enrollment. Thank you guys for watching.